hey welcome to The Bachelor breakdown
extras we're still with Kaitlyn talking
more questions about the bachelor and
here experience so what was your take on
Colt what do you think a Colton while
you were there I mean just like Cassie
said on a scale of 1 to life super nice
guy and I know fine journey wasn't as
long as some of the other girls but he's
he's great you were saying that you
didn't know him before signing on to
this show so yeah watch his season then
after you found us yeah no no I didn't
do any research do you think if you were
there longer that you may have fallen
for him is it that kind of guy that you
would fall for absolutely he's super
genuine and he stayed true to herself
while I was there so yeah he's the kind
of guy that if I saw him in a bar I
would put this whole virgin thing like
big ABC keeps bringing it up he keeps
bringing up did you did you ladies talk
about that was that an issue you guys
talk about the house was it's still
weird
and just like Cassie brought up to her
her date and the majority of us aren't
virgins and I have right now who did you
like in the house was there any
favorites like a juju barn with Elise
and I shared a room together we got
along really well I got along really
well with Alex be the other Canadian
right Kaitlyn and I hit it off too I
mean she when I went home something the
cutest no all of the girls were great
yeah didn't butt heads with any of them
I mean I didn't get close with a handful
of girls because you can't get along
with all 30 yeah yeah and that's not to
say that we didn't or that we were
fighting okay I kind of yeah
stayed with the girls that I connected
with and that way I could stay in my own
headspace and not get too involved in
everyone else and what do you do when
you're not on dates like what's going on
in the house Ilana are you allowed to
talk about sitting around
like you've got to be doing something
like I would just say they were driving
insane well honestly wait you're sorry
it was what we did a lot of lounging
yeah yeah working on your tan yeah
eating yeah what about the outfit you
want to know about the everyone has like
so for me when I'm packing to go
somewhere I need to know where I'm going
to like this night I'm wearing this this
night I'm wearing that like how do you
plan for all of these things that you
have no idea where you guys are gonna go
do how do you even pack for that it's
impossible and I honestly just threw
everything in my closet how many bags
are you guys allowed to bring um
we were told to bring two okay but I
mean nobody sucked it too there's no way
you can't yeah and you have your gowns
and everything the lot planning yeah
when you plan to stay to the bitter end
so you yeah however many cocktail dress
you got go okay good lure cocked up
might be going the beach may go in the
jungle you gotta prepare for all that
right yeah I mean the snow right you
don't know where you're going no there
is something that we we have to clear up
here we've been arguing about this
before yes it's when you did the group
date did you actually pull the limo I
say right like I can see that but I'm
sorry I can't and there's no way because
why because you found proof didn't you
because I saw a man at the back who was
possibly pushed yes yeah I don't see
that see I think you pulled the limo and
the man they have to keep it as
authentic as possible you guys yeah yeah
the car's not moving you could see me
jerking it and like really drunk once it
started rolling and got easier and
easier and I was like I told you told
you I always believed in you this one
didn't thank you so much for joining us
on what we're calling the extras thanks
so much thanks for watching we'll see
you in the breakdown next week
[Music]